border crisis also top of mind for
voters in Florida as the number of
migrants arriving in the Sunshine State
a Skyrocket 129 percent in just the past
two years Florida AG Ashley Moody joins
me now A.G Moody thanks for being here
how much is the Border crisis's impact
on Florida impacting the vote this year
causing Democrats to say hey I don't
like the Democrat policies I'm voting
Republican
you know I heard Biden mention just this
week and I almost came out of my chair
when he said there's so much at stake
the economy the safety of our streets
personal freedoms I'm like are you
making the argument for continuing our
great leadership in Florida for us
because these are things that are top of
mind I mean you say safety of the
streets let me tell you where that
starts securing our nation's borders
making sure that your Administration is
not purposefully disassembling the
structure that was in place to have
safety and Public Public Safety
immigration laws enforced there now
you're seeing record high amounts of
fentanyl flooding our streets you know
that when you have open borders and by
the way just since Biden took office the
numbers are astronomical nearly 5
million people that we know of have
tried to illegally enter the United
States that's more than the population
and half of our states it's more than
the population in a hundred count count
countries and territories across the
Globe I mean because of these policies
Biden has turned into the trafficker in
Chief we see increase in in human
smuggling trafficking drug trafficking
so when you're talking about safety of
our streets you have to start with the
border and it's laughable that they're
talking about the economy and personal
freedoms have they not been paying
attention to the last two years I mean
Florida keeps our eye on the ball we
want to do right by our citizens and
I've I've always said you know you do
your job you keep your head down work
hard make sure you're protecting the
rights of your citizens and their safety
the rest will just take care of itself
focusing on Florida polling for a moment
you Rubio DeSantis all up a big
continuing to lead what message are
Florida voters sending to the rest of
our country
Florida continues to stand out as a
state if you if you do the work if you
concentrate on the details of you make
sure that people feel safe in their
state and see that you're being
proactive that you are protecting not
just their their rights not just their
safety but they're you're pushing
Washington out of our ability to lead
the state the way our citizens want to
be led and the way they want to live
their lives I mean half my job as
attorney general is pushing nonsense out
of Washington when they try to cram it
down into our state this is such an
important election we don't agree on
most but I will agree with Biden this is
an important election for all the
reasons he said but we want to keep
Florida Florida we want to keep being
the flag bearer for the rest of this
nation and now and indeed the world
we're a shining example of what you can
do when you stay focused and you see
success you know it's been a tough
couple of years I think everyone would
admit that and we're seeing people move
here at record numbers and and great
prosperity and economic freedom and
safety for our citizens A.G Ashley Moody
best of luck thanks so much for joining
us